- So Sal here from Khan Academy,
and I'm excited to be
here with John Dickerson,
co-host of CBS This Morning.
- And I'm excited to be here too.
(Sal laughing)
- And some of you all might be wondering,
what are we doing together?
And we are going to be
talking about civics
and government and American history.
And you're gonna see a series of videos
on Kahn Academy tapping
into John's expertise.
- You know, when I cover
the news every single day,
one of the first things I do is I go back
and look at our amazing American
history for two reasons.
One, what has the
standard been in the past?
How have people behaved in the past?
So we know whether what's
happening now is new,
crazy, interesting, in keeping
with the American experience.
And the other thing is when
you learn about history,
when you look to the past,
you can sometimes have a clue
about what's gonna happen in the future.
Even though things are much
different now with technology
and the pace of things,
turns out, human beings
behave the same way
in a lot of ways all
throughout American history.
- So this is gonna be a very exciting,
as you could tell, series of videos
that some of 'em are
gonna be John and myself.
And some of 'em are gonna be John,
giving us kind of connecting
what you learn in school
to what's happening in
the world around us.